what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
I have my friend Stephen Kelly back with
me for our last hangout of 2017 and
today we're going to be talking about
smart tips for building your business in
2018 Stephen welcome aboard great to be
here again Evan for the last show of the
year
Stephen is all decked out in his
Christmas attire ready to kick us off
he's got the cufflinks and he's got the
socks
luckily no Curry's okay so it's that
time for those for those of you before
we go and kind of get started we've
celebrated a Merry Christmas and for
those of you don't is Happy Holidays but
this is and the good news is I know Evan
Carmichael is on this guy's good list
all year long so he's on Santa's super
good list
all right see we putting the good words
for me I love it I appreciate it
cool well you know my favorite part is
always hearing the Stephen Kelly quotes
kicking us off I know you've got a few
prepared what do you have for us this
month we got a few we got a few from
esteemed heroes and a couple of my own
one so starting with our Peter Drucker
who's obviously economist author manager
guru the best way to predict the future
is to invent it second one from
obviously a great American industrialist
Henry Ford
vision without execution is just
hallucination and then someone from or
Princeton down in Pennsylvania Albert
Einstein logic will take you from A to B
imagination will take you everywhere and
then someone from Shark Tank Barbara
Corcoran never underestimate the power
of your own instinct and then a kind of
triple whammy of quotes from Stephen
Kelly yes first of all two entrepreneurs
have the vision to see what others don't
second one no matter what the political
or social climate entrepreneurs will
always see opportunity and the third one
is one we've used before Evan a-class
execution and B class strategy
always wins against a class strategy and
B class execution so this is the time of
year where you know everyone we think
about it and you kind of golf on
holidays you see your loved ones and
then you kind of put these kind of
resolutions for 2018 together I guess
the whole purpose of this session today
is about thinking about what those
resolutions would be for all the
entrepreneurs out there to to get their
idea and make it happen
2018 is the year to make it happen so
what are the top tips we've got today to
help them really get their dreams lit up
and their passions kind of really Kindle
over the holiday period so they can come
out the gate in January and get going I
love it well first off I love the
Stephen Kelly addition to the quotes at
the beginning and I've seen them pop up
on Twitter and Instagram and the sharing
so so keep that up
great work your team there are those did
a good job behind the scenes too we've
got a whole bunch of questions already
kind of piling in and for those you're
watching leave your questions if you
tagged me it's way easier to see but
before diving in Stephen what are some
of your top tips for entrepreneurs 2018
new year fresh slate what do you what do
you want to get some advice on yeah I
think I will get loads of questions but
there's a couple of things I'd say is
you know it is a time particularly the
holy curve where you really get to it's
almost like when you go on a vacation
you can kind of sit on the beach or you
can climb a mountain whatever you you
know kind of really gets you float your
boat but it's a time when you can
reflect on what do you want to do with
the rest of your life what is the dream
and the big idea you want to make a
change to making the world a better
place so all of you out there today I
know I've got great ideas and it's just
making them land so I kind of think how
do we actually get started in many ways
so we hit the hit the gates run it when
it comes to January and then with all
these things you know if you get couple
of knock backs how do you overcome
adversity or or if you kind of get
momentum then you get rolling thunder'
and just a special call-out actually
Evan today for Kathleen Tate who was a
social work
from Chicago and she's been a big fan of
Evan since a gecko she's overcome some
huge adversity and she had some sort of
work-related disability injuries and
what she's done and big shout out for
her is she started her own clothing
store which is out in South Lake mall in
I think Indiana and Kathleen took some
inspiration from one of the early
hangouts very early on and she started
her own clothing range which is just
called goo just gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous one two gorgeous one big shout
out for gorgeous one which are clothes I
love this as well they're kind of tag
line close to inspire customers to
believe in themselves and her Twitter
handle is at George's 1 spelt GH o r J
us one so Kathleen if you if you're on
the show today we wanted to do that
shout out for you you are walking the
tool you live in the dream you're up
there out in Indiana and I hope you're
getting a lot of footfall today and I
hope everybody's hitting your website
your shop window and just saying wow
they're gorgeous one I've got the best
clothing out there and it allows me to
express myself so good luck to you in
your business and it's you know it's
fantastic Evan when I got that message
she DM me on Twitter and it just you
know if through these kind of hangouts
you know there's entrepreneurs out there
who take the conversations apply them to
their big idea and then start living
their dreams from you know Jan re1 then
there's nothing more that you and I can
do to feel so proud of them and just
feel very satisfied with the experience
that we build up where we can give the
next generation of entrepreneurs a kind
of help enhance to get on their journey
and live their adventure yeah I remember
Kathleen from she was at sea to summit
two years ago when was Chicago was yeah
two years ago yeah yeah yeah so she was
that's awesome and also just speaks to
just get in your
I'm out and reaching out to people and
like gdm Steven and boom here she is
getting the shout out is the first
person on this hangout so outreach has
to be a priority for you guys in 2018
I'm all about HIPAA got this and Evan
forgot it if you're there you're sitting
down and thinking about it it's kind of
five days away from the new year you're
thinking new year's resolutions
it's your big idea what do you go about
what do you start I think just taking
time to reflect on how you can play a
bigger game I think it's easy to get
locked into what you're doing and the
day to day and your yes your goals but I
think before getting to the goals is
having a bigger mindset and having a
bigger vision I know when you came in
and took over Sage and created your
multi-pronged strategy and then being
able to see it get executed with helping
the kids and helping the veterans and
helping women and the summit's and all
that just starting the new year by
thinking how can i play a bigger game
and then get into your goals get into a
state of confidence whether it's
watching this hangout and you're feeling
motivated you know if you couldn't fail
what would you do that kind of big
visionary thinking and then working down
to the tactics for what can I accomplish
this year I always find it to be super
helpful for me yeah I think evidence awe
and I think you and I've actually spoken
about this sort of end result planning
concept start with the end in mind you
never start with today you start with
maybe it's three four or five years
ahead and and great entrepreneurs always
live in the future
they obviously acknowledge the problems
we've got a kind of fix today but
they're living in the future they're
seeing the bigger vision how they can I
change the world with their product or
service their big idea and you guys can
absolutely I'd say just spend some
reflective time and maybe with your
loved one friends and family just to say
kind of shoot the breeze what could be
possible what's the biggest vision what
is the biggest face you could feel in
terms of your idea and what would it
look like if you say 2022 what would it
look like sitting out there in four
years time how big could it be how
you know how many countries get it going
how many you know how many evangelists
how many followers would you have all
these sort of things all the measures
and so how many awards would do it how
many customers would you have how many
literally how many invites would you
have either to water or the White House
because you're changing the world with
your big idea it's all those sort of
things and then obviously I think kind
of to to to your point evan is when you
start with the end you know your big
vision how you're gonna change you live
in the future
you really let let your imagination run
wild then you want to bring you back
itself back to well what do I need to do
on day one and a really easy way to do
that it's kind of start with three years
five years time the big vision and then
say well if that's the case what would I
have to do by 2020 what would I have to
do by 2019 and then what were I had to
do by December 31st 2018 so that gives
me 12 months so that's the case and I'm
gonna you know say by 2018 maybe having
done your big vision you say right I'm
gonna get a half a million dollars of
revenue I'm gonna have my product
launched in three countries I'm gonna
have kind of really big social media
presence I'm going to build a following
build a community and then you can kind
of bring it right back to well you know
that the six-month point the 3-month
point and then the 30-day point and then
what do you need to do on day one are
you gonna go and see who you're gonna
talk to who you're gonna be a hustler
with who's gonna be a partner who are
the gaps that you've got in terms of
your big vision how to make it happen so
and then actually twelve ins point again
you know it's great to hear here from
Kathleen but it's fantastic how to use
your network or how do you use the
network of 7 billion people out there
who could be all advocates for you to be
successful in your business with your
big idea because many of those people
you will find you don't even know today
right when I started this age my life
was poorer because I didn't know Evan
Carmichael yeah now my life is richer
because I know this guy and he's great
fun but there's you know when you start
your business you will meet amazing
people
so how do you kind of get them early on
to be a catalyst of growth and success
in your business how do you get them to
give you advice how do you get them
maybe to give you funding how do you get
them to give you access to markets all
these sort of things so it's kind of go
right back to the beginning then but you
know and Evan and think about the big
vision and then bring it back to today
what do I need to do January 1 January
to January 3 I love it
well guys and other questions are
pouring in if you tag me it's a lot
easier for me to see them but let's get
the sound that's the point of this
hangout let's get to your questions
first up is Jackson writing in the say I
would like to know how to develop a good
work ethic for 2018 oh that's great hey
Jackson I think it's important there is
gonna be a you know I think truthfully
I'd say things to everybody really all
my friends were family colleagues and
sage yeah yeah work ethic is important
to success ah and people who typically
work harder sibley tend to be more and
there's loads of books like 10,000 hours
all these books written about you know
the amount of effort you put into your
idea has a strong correlation with you
being you know a kind of Jedi Master
ultimately you're gonna be a Jedi Master
entrepreneur then you're gonna have to
work at it and you're gonna have to
learn continuously now if you kind of if
you don't have that work I think the
only way you kind of probably get rich
is to win the lottery and you got to get
lucky there see if I have got to be
really lucky and lazy or you've gotta
have a work ethic and then Yin being on
to an earn you'll be super successful
and Fanny let you do that I'd suggest a
few things I think I kind of think
structure probably three things
structure is really important in terms
of you know getting up every morning
same sort of time getting a regular
sleep eating well diet exercise all
those sort of things you know and and
just get it cadence and a rhythm where
you're feeling confident feeling good
about yourself feeling feeling energized
so structures the first one and then
kind of the other thing secondly is just
just
in terms of work ethic again think about
what it what is it I want to do if
that's my big vision for three years my
big vision for one year my mo what is my
kind of milestones I've got to hit this
month and then bring it back to work so
it means I've got to do three things
really well today and then get very
focused on those so it's kind of whether
you call it a to-do list ask this but
make sure it's outcome based it's not
about doing the process it's about
achieving the results and and that gives
you real focus and then the other thing
I'd say especially as an entrepreneur is
you know celebrate be kind to yourself
you know it's so easy and I do this one
of my failings that I probably just am
never satisfied with myself I always can
do better but I'd advise all
entrepreneurs to say actually some days
and some days go really well and you
know what it's like being an
entrepreneur it is a daily ride a
white-knuckle ride you're on the roller
coaster of entrepreneurship and you go
up and down up and down and some days
you win an order you're feeling like you
can fly to the moon the next day
something goes wrong in the business or
you're just about to hire someone and
they take another job
you know you feel flat so I think you've
got to be kind to yourself and you've
got to celebrate your successes even if
you're on your own you should just say
wow I should just savor that moment I
should really enjoy the success of
winning my first customer always
remember maybe take a little video of
yourself so how did you feel when you
won the first customer and then posting
it and sharing it with your friends and
then you'll get laughs and I think being
an entrepreneur particularly if you're
starting on your own you need a support
network you need to fill you're part of
a bigger community for a bigger courts
and there's lots of ways you can do that
but be kind to yourself though so there
would be the kind of three things one
structure to focus and three be kind to
yourself I like it all the things I
think I don't celebrate probably enough
for the things that I'm doing so it's a
good good reflection for me too
in terms of work ethic what I would say
is one have important goals that mean
something to you it's really hard to
wake up and do something you hate every
day and work really hard at it you know
so to
Steve and I were talking before how to
set goals having something that you are
generally looking forward to doing where
it doesn't feel like it's just insane
work all the time you're actually having
a passion you love doing it it's really
important I don't know that there's lazy
people I think people just have
uninspired goals and then - I just say
the environment really matters you know
when I walk in here this means something
to me this gets me inspired to get in
and start working and that's part of my
morning routine if you ever have the
good fortune to visit Stevens offices in
in London his desk is with everybody
else there's no like private fancy
corner suite offices that's Stevens desk
there and that's everybody else he likes
working alongside his team
shoulder-to-shoulder and so you know
whatever the environment that you need
to create for yourself to give you the
energy on a regular basis I think is
really important so I would just add the
Stevens points one goals that motivate
you into an environment supports the
best for you coming down yah-tchi evan
the other thing i think there's loads of
reasons psychologically it's a great
time to start a business in the new year
because you know all the new year's
resolutions all that stuff but there's a
lot of sensible things just to say
because typically you get better tax
benefits in countries like Canada the US
UK if you kind of incorporate a business
at the start of the year actually also
the other thing if you're looking to
hire people people start looking around
kind of January February March people
people don't look kind of in the summer
holidays for jobs so you know you social
media if you want to rent you reach out
through LinkedIn and stuff like that
you kind of Tim you find more resources
available and also just in terms of the
whole cycle of if you're raising money
or if you're asking your friends to fund
your business people tend to kind of
work on an annual cycle and it just
tends to be a calendar cycle and they
look at their portfolio at the end of
the year and then they start the new
year and they look again and look
everybody starts afresh so it's kind of
a good time for resources for funding
and also kind of a good environment for
tax benefits and stuff like that so
there's a lot of kind of logical
business reasons and it's just a good
time where Joe Evans point I think we
all have a cadence in in our bodies our
psyches and
in the new year you come in with huge
optimism and confidence and you know
you've had reflection time and downtime
and hopefully good rest over the
holidays and you come up really
confident and powering ahead so it's a
great time to give your the art idea the
best chance of being successful I love
it
keep the Russians coming in guys next
one we have is tree aunt bee gee I don't
know if that's how you pronounce it
Stephen and Evan how do you transition
from a day job and building a business
should you start part-time and then as
you expand quit your job what are your
thoughts that's a great question and
some of the best startup businesses that
became global mammoths I've done that
and I guess I call it this isn't a very
fair phrase that should really kind of
classify the language
I call it moonlight it I think
moonlighting is a great way to start a
new business so I would have actually
example it's Marc Benioff who is a
amazing leader chairman CEO of
Salesforce got massive respect for was
working at Oracle and working on his
startup which were Salesforce and I know
loads of people and I always advocate
because you know if you're in a job even
if it's a part-time job then it kind of
gives you some cash flow bit security
you know if you've got a family and
stuff like that but also it means that
you can allow your business idea to get
off to a point in time and I think you
have to look it you have to make sure
you you plan this and you go into it
with your eyes open because there comes
a point where it's almost like kind of
jumping out of a plane with the
parachute you say this is the point when
I'm gonna give up my kind of full-time
job or my part-time job and I'm going to
devote a hundred percent of my time and
200 percent of my energy to my new
adventure but what a great way to get
effectively someone else to fund your
dreams and start your business and
certainly do all the kind of preliminary
work like test your idea test your idea
with the market maybe get your first few
customers and when you've got sufficient
momentum that you say wow this is a real
business and I'm really confident of it
my ideas coming true they
that's the time to you know cut the cord
and fly like an eagle and go full-time
yeah for me I think it depends on your
personality type I think some people the
only way they do something is if they go
all-in on it and that's the only way
that they can get anything done for me I
hate spending money till I'm making
money and I would much rather do a
part-time job a part-time business sorry
to fund my idea and have a job at the
same time and then when you make enough
money just to survive not not like get
crazy cars or anything but like pay the
internet bills you know just just
survive then that's when you quit I
would also say I think it's really
important that you take a job where
you're gonna learn something that will
help you in your business so don't think
some dead-end nine-to-five job that's
just paying the bills for you get
something where you're going to learn
something from it whether it's sales or
marketing their product irrelevant or
whatever it is that you lack that you
want to get better at the reason to get
a job is to be able to learn some new
skills and develop yourself but then you
could bring to your business so I would
also if you're in that position that'll
look at your job and see maybe you need
to make an adjustment get another job
answer your business on the side yeah I
think yeah I did you know I love urban
as well just reflecting it you always
bring a great perspective things as a
sort of very humor perspective I love
that I think um the the thing you also
said about a part-time job you just then
you've also got to be pragmatic because
if your idea needs a hundred percent
revenge in time you've got to give it
the best chance so if it gets to a stage
where you're kind of fault on the part
time jobs constraining your ability to
execute on your plan for your big idea
then you have to make different choices
the other thing I'd say just sitting
here this there's some folks in Sage
actually who have come to me and said
you know I want to be here but one day I
want to have my own business and I want
to start my own business and I've got
big ideas and I want to pursue my
passion and and people I kind of think
for some reason think that employers
think that they'll be negative about
that but when people tell me that I am
so excited for them and if they can
start their idea while being a employer
in
sage then fantastic you know so I think
what I'm saying is if you went to a
full-time job yeah or a part-time job go
in an industry that you care about and
it's something that gives you a catalyst
to start right it doesn't make sense if
you're gonna start a company working at
Starbucks
but you should go into technology but
don't think that everybody's gonna be
trying to beat you up on your idea so
I'd say generally always err on the side
towards honesty and share with your boss
or whoever you're working for one day
you've got your dream of starting your
idea and you've got this business idea
spending weekends and evenings on and
you know might come a time if you're
successful that you step in and you're
like that that that boss to celebrate
your success and wish all the well for
the future now I would say human nature
I've always said and people always
surprise you on the positive so you
might find a lot of the companies
certainly when Benioff was there he got
full support from Oracle in terms of
these big idea there was no kind of
perceived conflict and I think I think
you know tree and BG I think it's about
giving yourself enough cash flow to pay
the bills but as soon as your new idea
takes off and gives you a subsistence
level then you should go but also is
it's great in a startup business in and
out of business I always tell everybody
treat the company's money as if it's
your own and I love I love you know is
Evan talks to Bella's hustlers I talk
about like it's great to actually run
companies on fumes in some respects
because if you really care about every
dollar you'll have a really good culture
that you can then build in your company
and make everybody to have the same
values that you have so I think it's
good every now I just wanted to give you
a bit of a personal comment there and
you bring a very human perspective to
living the life of dreams I don't know
what to say I always appreciate it man I
love it I'm humbled I'm humbled and then
I last four words which is rare I want
to move on to a super fan of yours who's
asking the questions that you were
talking about values he said Stephen
so this is row as in Monroe Steven you
are able to save sage and really turn
the company around what is your one word
core value and how did you use it to
lead sage to success
that's a great question well I'd
probably say authenticity that shall
give you two words customers I've done
everything from the get-go just love in
living customers and how you make them
delight it is you really kind of get
your colleagues to believe in the vision
the mission the noble cause we're very
lucky at Sage because you know we
support you guys and when I and I spend
a lot of time outside the office I've
spent a lot of time meeting
entrepreneurs and every time I meet
entrepreneurs you know they connect my
heart and their head and sometimes I got
tears in my eyes when they tell me their
stories this is a very emotional journey
for them they've been on it's a story of
human sacrifice and that appeals to me
and I think it appeals to all our
colleagues so just a one word would be
customers customers customers customers
everything we do is about customers and
I'm ro I think you know it's really kind
of what you said buys I just think we've
got so much more to do it's back to
Evans point I'm never satisfied with
myself I'm busting my chops saying it
Steven even do better and we can but
yeah we've made progress but I'm still
not happy with where we are and you know
I genuinely want our customers and
sometimes you meet customers who are
massive advocates and raving fans but I
want all of our customers to be you know
just turn around of me and saying
because we know these the guys who are
with us today out here Evan are the
business heroes of the economy you're
the risk takers you're the entrepreneurs
you're the crafters and you deserve
awesome technology and you should put
all your energy and to grow in your
business winning new customers to grow
in the top-line hiring more people you
shouldn't have to worry about technology
we should take care of that there's a
follow-up question from row asking why
would you recommend Sage accounting for
small business /e com
over QuickBooks and what features do you
think small business owners will love
about it I hear oh it's great I'm gonna
I'll give you about a few seconds demo
in a minute that way because this isn't
about you know sage we want to make it
about you and your dreams and getting
ready for next year but what you should
do is kind of check out the web cam web
site on Sage accounting there's a number
of loads of kind of features but at most
of all I mean it's great on kind of
mobile we believe entrepreneurs on the
move can run their business both from
the palm of their hand or if they want
to you know do on our laptops great
usability fantastic product it's all you
know again I guess we've just done a lot
of work actually I think ever might have
seen somewhere around sage business
cloud where we could be the one and only
cloud platform that our customers will
need for the whole of their life as they
grow their business and we've got some
amazing customers like we've got twenty
thousand employees so as you grow your
business when you get to a certain stage
things like changing your accounting
system honestly despite what some
companies say it's like open-heart
surgery and we think we've got a
responsibility as you grow your business
and you expand your business to make
that transition as easy as possible and
for you guys not to worry about the
technology and then the final thing Roe
is because we're nice guys okay
you couldn't believe how much we care so
I tell you what if you become a customer
of sage I've said this before any
customer you know we've got over three
million customers any customer who
tweets dm's me pings me a message on
social calls me sends an email to me
even they get an immediate response we
we care so much about our customers
being successful what you know whether
it's the end of tax yes is tax EEOC's
the year-end whether it's they're trying
to pay their employees whether they're
trying to collect cash whatever they're
trying to do if they ever hit a problem
then then we always will be standing
with them shoulder to shoulder and again
I think truthfully technology companies
we've probably been guilty of this but
just generally the technology industry
it's been great as selling sort of a
vision but when it comes to fixing
problems
they've typically have not always been
the best and the truth is for any
journey I think Evan would vouch for
this there's always some bumps in the
road nothing ever goes perfectly nothing
ever goes perfectly to plan but I can
guarantee if you ever hit a bump in the
road with sage you can pick up the phone
to me and we'll jump on it we'll be
shoulder to shoulder to you and we'll
get you back in your business and
focusing on what you love which is
pursuing your passions as quick as we
get I love it I would just add to just
the simplicity a guy you safety in my
business I only talk about the products
that I actually use and I use QuickBooks
I don't know a while ago and a lot
honest like a lot of the accounting
software packages they do a lot of the
same functionality most businesses are
not super technical or unique crazy
features it's just you want to get in
and get it done quickly like you don't
want to spend a ton of time doing your
accounting right we have stuff to do and
for me I just like how easy everything
is to use it just makes sense you don't
have to be genius to be able to use it
everything's integrated with your bank
and calculating taxes and all that stuff
so on top of having an awesome visionary
CEO and a great company culture I just
love how easy the tool is to use and I
use it all the time in my business that
was great Thank You ro for the love
buying fro let's move on the Emmanuel
Evan and Steven so you're in London and
Toronto is living in a big city an
important part of your success hey
that's a great question actually and you
know I'm really conscious a lot of you
know a lot of startup businesses have
gone to Toronto it's probably one of the
hot beds in North America now for
startups and likewise London other
cities like Berlin Paris
Alcee New York so it is a factor I think
you know what what is it that makes
these cities I guess a vibrant hotbed
for startups I think actually it's about
the network because if I'm living in you
know pick pick the great country of
Canada if I'm living out in Calgary or
Winnipeg out in the plains they're
amazing people they're amazing kind of
business parks is there and credit
Wi-Fi broadband yeah yeah there is
everything's there but there might not
be in certainly in rural areas the kind
of network of people you need in terms
of mentorship experience coaching
guidance and how you get that is I think
you can be more proactive so if they're
on your door stop in a big city yeah
it's easier but I don't think there's
anything to stop you if living in a kind
of rural community being successful as
an entrepreneur and obviously you know
I've seen businesses launch in the last
five years you know I just give you
three or four businesses some of these
have been in in cities but some of them
haven't this open door billion-dollar
business wasn't here five years ago
obviously instacart
again to billion-dollar business our
personal shop in I wasn't here five
years ago sort of you before groceries
and then another one pivotal another
multi-billion dollar business these
companies didn't exist five years ago so
the speed you can get your idea to
market and create real high-value
businesses there's never been a better
time and I would say yeah there's the
advantage cities have there's an easy
accessible network but if you're again
if you're a proactive if you're a bit of
a hustler if you're bold then you can
create your own network you can create
your own community and you can do that
anywhere in the world and and the beauty
is we're in Toronto we're in London ten
years ago we couldn't do this other
stuff because the technology now
technology you know whether it's
FaceTime whatever it is there's just so
much technology where you can create
communities of multicultural multi
language and you can get people together
to support your big idea and what do you
think you're in Toronto yes I'm just
thinking your corporate like your
corporate headquarters is in this the
shard you know the most prestigious
building in London but most of your team
is not in London right there and we got
tub yeah we've got a big headquarters in
new cars will go a couple of thousand
people up there but you know it's
interesting I don't think it's funny I
never think of a headquarters I think
our people are wherever they need to be
to serve
our customers and where do i go i getta
where our people are and our customers
are and just that's the philosophy so
and I really don't mind whether you know
I'm we could be out in Richmond in in
West Canada or we could be out in
Toronto we could be anywhere and I do
trips actually to kind of rural
communities as well to see our customers
because we've got customers who are in
farming and all these sort of fantastic
businesses and I think you just got to
go where first of all where customers
are obviously where the audience is
where you can attract great people
that's important but now as well Evan
you're absolutely right because we don't
hire all our people in one location
there's so many amazing people around
the world with great skills and and they
enable through technology and
communication to offer a very different
sort of business model and a different
landscape than what was possible 20
years ago um and and I think just you
guys I'm kind of assuming most year
Millennials you're probably a lot of you
under 30 and I think you think in a much
more radical way now around this agenda
where it's all about flexibility it's
all about where you want to be living
that really meets your sort of personal
goals but you can i'm guarantee anywhere
in Canada anywhere in the u.s. anywhere
in the UK you could live and you could
still I have a really good opportunity
to you know follow your dreams get your
idea to market and create a great
business yeah you might take on that
question I look at I look at customer
suppliers at employees I so it depends
on the type of business you're running
so can you can your customers be global
if they can it doesn't matter where you
are if it has to be a local shop then
obviously you need to have a local shop
you know mice in my dancing business
China dance salsa we need it's a local
place you need people around you as a
retail store right so you need people
coming in for making YouTube videos it
could be anywhere in the world suppliers
you know if you're if you're in the
lumber business you want to be next to
lumberyard right like it just depends on
where you are for you to business like
this my suppliers could be anywhere and
then employees is just access to talent
some cities have greater access to
talent
if you need to have an office and have
people come in they may not be willing
to relocate to some rural town but if
you can hire online hire a remote then
that could be a fantastic model so I
think it depends on the business
structure that you have the type of
product you're selling but I think it's
it matters less and less with every year
matters less and less and less and less
and less it's less and less important
you've been looking at Sage and a
strategy around the sage summit you know
a couple years ago the history was one
big event one big city Atlanta Chicago
and then last year how many did you do
20 yeah and we had 30,000 customers
attend and this year is going even more
kind of nationwide around all the
countries we operate in so and and they
tend to be I like in candor your great
nation I love Canada
so Evan Halifax ala facts Nova Scotia
amazing place Winnipeg Calgary 20 cities
across Canada we went on the road we
went to where our people are where our
customers are we went where the audience
is and I think you can do that the other
thing is very important there Evan so we
started off with Chicago 15,000 people
ever and show there was one of the best
ever loved it it was fantastic so now
the shows go on the road was a summit
and there last week there were up I
think in Birmingham in the UK and then
they've got a whole raft of North
American cities they're going round two
in 2018 I think if you can catch them
check them out it's all on the website
the other thing I'd say Evan it's
interesting your point is kind of where
the customers and what's the business
model we've got a few customers kind of
an interesting business model they've
got on really like they're crashing its
food and products food products and
they've opened up a restaurant in their
local town but they've actually built
merchandising so they market the product
through their website and they've
truthfully they make more money through
the merchandise and then they do through
the restaurant and obviously kind of the
merchandising can do what we love to see
in terms of our top-line growth and
obviously you've got very little fixed
cost around merchants
and whereas restaurants cost a lot of
money you've got kind of real estate you
got loads of stuff you got loads of
stuff you've got to take on in terms of
the cost base before you kind of hit to
break even and I'm scared I'm a
notoriously tough to actually scale
multiple restaurants so it's interesting
you've got to think about what business
model you got then where should it be
located and it comes back to where the
customers where your employees where the
supplies and ultimately how do you scale
it and grow it to go the next level and
it's interesting where you get these
kind of multifaceted business models
which is a restaurant and a product
business merchandising and it's just
interesting where you're gonna make
money I like it well mind burst TV put
in quotes I don't think I've
headquarters but I think of people whose
needs we need to serve and then said I
love that statement so if you're looking
for your next Instagram or a tweet out
get get Darryl on it get some love on
burst TV it's already got evidence on it
Darryl's on it he's done
Salima is writing in to say evidenced
even if you could do one thing every
year to ensure success what would that
be always do what you said always
meeting your commitments to yourself I
guess but ultimately customers so so and
why do I say that Salima it's time ever
and opened up saying ultimately it was
kind of great words to just have a plan
and the plan just could be for today but
it's hats focus well what am I going to
achieve today or what am I going to
achieve this week or what I won't
achieve this month and what does that
mean to our customers and Salima if you
do that and there's one thing you
actually take that off and say we kind
of blew through that that's probably the
one thing that you may make sure you do
now if you don't and not everything goes
perfectly and now everything goes to
plan then what do we learn what what
happened you know what went well but
what what would been even better is if
we're done something differently you
know maybe like if we're in a web
business SEO optimization or social
media or you know channel mix or
whatever it is what is it we would
change
based on our experience of what didn't
go so well that would allow us to get
much better results next time and we
talked about it in terms of course
correction so everything I think in a
startup business should be agile
everything in a big company like us
should be agile and it's not just the
way we develop products is every
function should be agile so when you
think as an entrepreneur think on your
feet put a plan together have an end
result on it time box it and then
execute the hell out of it and then
either congratulate yourself and go on
to the next one learning even more and
growing even faster or if not then what
do you need to do to course-corrected to
get it back on track I like it we're
getting a lot of love in the chat thank
you love it thanks Steven so believe
Nations a fan what would one thing I
would do each year to ensure success I
approached it from a mindset perspective
I think the more that I can hang around
people who challenge me to do more I
think I think that always ensures my
success so I think the more talks I have
a Steven the more I watch a Steve Jobs
video or the more read a biography of
somebody just constantly making sure
that there's people resources in your
environment that push you to think
bigger be bolder play a larger game I
think making sure that I would say not
even just once a year but that's it's a
constant thing that you have things that
challenge you and stretch you I think
that is something that I try to do to
maintain my success each year yeah
actually every one other thing I think
as you grow and you become more
successful some companies kind of Leaves
lose a sense of purpose and the sense of
purpose is always described by two
communities it's your colleagues the
people who work for you and with you and
it's your customers so and it's so easy
in a bigger company to go to all these
internal meetings and you you know the
end the day you kind of think what did I
achieve today if I and if those meetings
hadn't existed would it have changed the
world for our customers so one thing I
don't always do is you get more and more
successful and I do this not only every
year but I do this every month
go back to the people you love that you
started your idea and your dream for and
that's your customers go and if and
either face time and so I just want to
catch up with you I just want your
feedback how you doing with our product
what could we do to improve it for you
you know good and and you know maybe get
it as you build your firm as you build
your business as you build your company
you you you could even I've talked about
this before maybe give I don't know your
top ten customers who are the thought
leaders who will move the whole market
maybe give them a tiny bit of stock in
your company but part of the deal is
they become references they go on your
website and every month or every quarter
they do a kind of check in with you what
do we need to do next in terms of
innovation what how can we leave the
competition behind and so I'd always the
one thing I do every year every month
every week every every day is make sure
you bring the customer in the room and
and as you know I don't know you get to
20 people 30 people I've known kind of
chief executives sort of start losing
touch because you get drawn into
internal stuff I'd always say go back to
why you exist in Amway starting your
business the first place that's to serve
customers with your big idea feeling the
customer love just oozing out of Stephen
Kelley's veins I love it next up is
Orion Husain Stephen and Evan which kind
of people should you hire for your
startup highly talented individuals with
no real passion or normal talented
people with the burning passion for the
startup I think in the early stage I
think it changes over time
Iran in the early stages there's a few
things and everyone will have some great
great insight here I aren't hard people
with passion odd people yeah and I'd
tell them it's almost like the pitch so
imagine your business and you've got a
fantastic business in five years time
and you know you're a major brand what's
up on the wall say and why you existed
and what what's the sense of purpose
what's the mission so you should tell
people in the interview process you know
that's the mission that's what we're
here this is how we're going to change
this is why I get excited and get up at
6 o'clock every morning if they get your
passion you're you you're gonna be sick
you're gonna have a great chance of
being successful if they don't get your
passion and they don't get the passion
for the big idea then I I think it's
just nice to be polite and finish the
conversation there and find someone
who's passionate I think they have to
have your passion then that's the really
important thing as well is I think you
need to sort of profile yourself what
are you really good at um none of us are
good at everything so you know you good
at marketing and you've got ideas you've
got a product development you've got a
website are you good in terms of kind of
run of the book spam paying the bills
keep it the cash flow going all these
sort of things I'll ask yourself what
really gets you excited and this is
where you have to be true to yourself
don't don't kind of fake it so because
we're all different and some people like
assails are marked and they love to get
out they were customers some people kind
of want to build structure and you know
have a good finance very you know all
that sort of stuff now the reason why
I'm saying that Iran is you want to
surround yourself probably in the early
stages with people who have who share
the passion but people who complement
your gaps so if you look at yourself and
say actually that's a gap I need someone
who can do a great job of customer
service because I'm not you know what I
am is I am great at going out this isn't
about me this is just a hypothetical
situation but I am great ago now and
building a compelling kind of value
proposition around my big idea and
putting out on the website and
attracting loads of customers one not
very good at is getting those customers
on-boarded live get customer
satisfaction through the roof but that's
something that's really important to my
success as a business so I need someone
who's going to do that follow-up because
I need to go and get the next wave of
customers so I think kind of number one
they have to show your passion number
two you should really look hard of
yourself and what you're really
competent at and what you're really good
at and what what really is your DNA and
then surround yourself with the next
hire who compliments you and delivers
the most
important impact for the growth of your
business yeah when I think about
questions like this I think of Jim
Collins and embrace the genius at the
end whenever you put like do I do this
or do this like the answer is both you
know to have a successful business it's
going to be depend on your team as you
build up the amount that you contribute
goes it decreases as you build up your
team right so you need to have stars on
your team and so the challenge is if you
hire somebody who has passion but then
doesn't have any skills you have
somebody who's like really committed but
isn't isn't giving you the output and
then somebody who has the talent but
doesn't have passion you're never going
to win their hearts and souls and so now
you're stuck with a good person instead
of going for somebody who's potentially
great and you need a great team to be
able to build up and so whenever faced
with those kind of this or this question
I would challenge all of you to think
about the end how do I make both of
these things happen and it's worth the
time to find that one person who is the
end than to hire three people who are
just good and then you're getting
mediocre results as you go down another
I teach I just apply that to every or
this or this question quickly from
Tamara C when she's writing in to say
there's nothing like hearing SK talk
about his love for customers he loves
his customer know he loves his customers
heart from his heart and like three
heart emojis coming in so lemma thanks
Tamara you know I think I'm actually
ever not talked about it yeah I just get
so excited about you know customers and
when you're here I spend a lot of time
when you hear their love their passion
and you know some of these customers
have been in business two years some of
them 20 years and they still Wow they
still feel that energy about their dream
and their business and being their own
boss and all these silly things and and
you know I just I'm in all of them so
I'm very privileged and I'm very lucky
and very humble actually to serve them
and just hopefully always be a great
partner to I think that's a really
important point too and that
and building a team like you guys here
how much Steven loves customers and in
every episode you guys are the hardcore
fans you've seen him talk every episode
about customers it's not just talking to
something he actually feels and so
building a team up around people who
love customers like you could be a
really talented marketer or really
talented programmer but if you don't
care about the sage customer that this
product is going to be in the hands of
then there's not a there's not a place
for you like this isn't that right
company to be a part of you have to love
customers to be in this business and I
think when people can understand what
that value is then it's easy to attract
the right people to the business - yeah
I think I actually have another thing
about hiring people is sort of related
is and you've talked about is it's the
values you want you want the next
generation to have the same values that
you care about that customers about
winning about growth about all that
growth mindset and and people who
generally are optimistic I think great
entrepreneurs and early-stage companies
are full of amazing optimists you kind
of don't want someone who's gonna tell
you a thousand reasons and why you can't
do stuff you want people to say yeah
there's loads of issues all you want
people actually and something I do in
interviews when I interview people
sometimes I ask them this question I say
tell me what's been the worst worst
worst day of your life professionally in
business what's the worst day and then
how did you overcome it and you'll get a
great sense you know coz experience and
attitude overcoming adversity we all
know it is tough being the start of is
tough and there's some amazing days and
days when you're doing kind of
somersaults when you leave and some days
we you know you think oh this is really
a grind but you don't want to be
surrounded by people who just say yes to
you but you and you didn't want to
challenge from them but you do want them
to be optimists and winners because
because winners attract winners and then
the other thing is to always have people
bet on yourself and you will find you
because you've got to think ahead in two
years time these people you're hiring
today will be hiring you know three or
four people themselves
so will they attract the next generation
for years you've grown Skelly company
and will they do with integrity and the
values that you hold true to yourself I
love it
well you give you a lot more love in the
comments thank you excellent advice and
insight Wow good dialogue I'm a huge fan
getting some good love here
the next question ties into that that
idea around mindset so comes from Rick
and he says question for both of you
what are some common mindsets that you
would suggest that people need to change
or adopt to start seeing a better
business and culture and 2018 so I think
hey Rick it's good question I think
mindset is really important so generally
I think all the entrepreneurs I meet are
just amazing optimists great lovers of
life so the sort of mindset here you can
read about this there's there's things
called the growth mindset and actually
kind of the other the other one is day
one mindset and and it just talks about
doing some doing the basics really well
it talks about putting customers first
it talks about execution it talks about
a lot of things we've said but it really
encapsulates it and very easy to
understand a language that you can then
reflect in terms of your mindset but
also then your actions and attitude so I
think you want to be you want to be out
there with winners and you'll attract
winners and I think mindset is really
important because you've not got to only
believe yourself and I love that hashtag
believe Evan if you believe you'll
inspire not only colleagues but you'll
inspire your customers and they'll
believe with you and that's a very very
powerful combination what do you think
Evan yeah I love it growth mindset day
one mindset a huge fan of both to add I
would say just the mindset of taking
responsibility for where you're at I
think I think the people who achieve are
not complainers you don't complain about
the government or the president or taxes
or whatever because as long as it's
somebody else's fault then you don't
have to do anything and I think the
people who succeed yes they have
challenges and often the people who
succeed had the most challenges growing
up and over
insane adversity to Stevens question
around what was the biggest problem that
you faced and how did you overcome it
you'll find that the the people who
overcame huge odds had every reason to
give up the people have the most success
had had every reason to complain and
give up and call it in and everybody
would have understood and said well
that's totally understandable but they
didn't accept that they didn't complain
didn't blame anybody they took
responsibility for where they were in
life and they changed it and so I think
a good habit would be looking yourself
in the mirror and ask yourself why am I
not more successful than I that I you
know then then I should be and see what
comes back and if the answer isn't
something related to you the answer is
your parents or something else then then
you're in the complaining mindset and
you have to adjust it to take more
responsibility for what you are
yeah it's a great point I love it we're
we're getting tight on time I want to
fit one more in let's see yeah a Jing
Kia is asking to follow a question
around hiring people with passion so
writing in to say how to find the people
with passion when you're starting up
hey I drink tea I think what kind of
look at your network your social media
network and then there's again things
like linkedin there's loads of tools out
there to find who are people who express
themselves with passion who are
interested in your idea and her great
great compliment for you and and again
here be bold don't give up have never
give up this there's so many people
there just so I gave you the example of
Kathleen she reached out to Evan she
reached out to me I reach out to prove
you cannot you cannot underestimate how
generous people are with their time to
help you be successful
honestly all we want to see is a whole
volunteer army of great entrepreneurs
out there start their business live
their dreams and there's generally
people who have made it serial
entrepreneurs I've typically found them
the most generous people in terms of
giving their time and advice to the next
generation so and and through their
network you know every time you see some
of the hustler
honestly I even I do it now I say have
you seen the amazing people any I'm
looking I'm on a mission for rock stars
so where are the rock stars you know I
wanna harm rock stars you must have some
names think about it think about it
here's my card
think about rock stars this is what I'm
looking for this is the sort of you know
amazing social media or amazing
marketing or whatever the role is and
you just say we've gotta find rock stars
and they do think about it and then you
get the best way to hard people I've
always found is probably through the
extended network because people don't
like to recommend anybody that's not a
rock star and and you and I know Evan
he's a rock so people you meet in life
there's so many great people and if you
can give them a leg up and give them an
opportunity to the next role the next
big idea then that's something which
would be very noble a hundred percent
agree the only thing I would add is
always lead with your your mission and
your values so Steven loves customers
then if I was hiring a programmer the
the job title would be programmer who
loves customers yeah and then lead with
what we're trying to do and then
somebody would read that and say that's
the stupidest job I've ever seen I don't
care about customers I just care about
code great don't apply like you're not
gonna be a fit at this company and
others are gonna say wow that's really
amazing finally a company that actually
cares about customers I want to feel
like the work I'm doing is meaningful
and so people will self select in based
on what you're putting out and so that's
how you can attract people to you
instead of if you just have a boring job
ad or a boring website then you get a
mix of everybody and nobody that truly
cares about you so just really lead with
your your mission and your values first
Steven we're we're getting up at the end
of the hour here I'd love to hear your
your final thoughts for our final video
in 2017 leave believe nation with some
inspiration to head into the new year I
love it so hey you
first of all web and I just want a
personal message to Nina to say I was
lucky enough to me Evans partner in
London and give a big hugs and you know
for the holiday season you know have a
restful and superb time and then also I
think for everybody out there you know
again though the words of a great leader
Martin Luther King in terms of climbing
that giant staircase just take the first
step and there's no better time than
taking the first step then when you come
back in January and you've had a great
hopefully amazing kind of restful time
over the holidays with your loved ones
your family your friends to come back in
and just say I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
make it happen
I'll do it with no regrets because if
you sat there in ten years time and said
well I didn't do it you'll have regrets
if you do it and take the risk and back
yourself and believe honestly it will
start the best adventure of your life so
you know we're back in you we're all
back in you and I would say actually
Evan we we love doing these I'd be
useful for everybody out there we I
always enjoy and always look forward in
my week to having a chat with Evan and
in the hangouts and we hope they're
useful to you I love your questions Ben
great questions again today so thank you
very much and finally just to wish all a
happy holiday coming up and in the year
ahead 2018 hit the ground running and
yeah this time believe man go make it
happen make it happen I love it what are
we going to end it well thank you Sivan
so much your time your advice your
wisdom your heart your care thank you
guys so much for watching and all the
fantastic questions we didn't get all of
them but we're gonna keep it going into
the new year and look forward to meeting
you there thanks for thanks for
everything have a fantastic close to
your week continue to believe and we'll
see you soon